i haven't seen you since your back thing
so how you're good obviously
uh yeah i'm absolutely i literally had
the x-ray results in about two days ago
really yeah because i've still got this
rod in my back and i've got like
screws oh yeah i'm seriously i mean the
scars like that big
um you're wearing a rod in your back
right now i have
st i have titanium in my body yeah wow
you're like a robot you're part robot
yeah yes i'm like
you are what is what was his name the
terminator you know his part whatever
um well what was your son's reaction did
he freak out my kids freak out when i
even have a needle in my arm to get
blood or something
well it's a good question it was because
you know that movie up
you know right you know the guy who was
on the thing you know where he's
standing up
yeah with the tennis balls so i had came
back
like what's he gonna think how do i
explain it
so lauren told him that you know
basically what had happened
that i've got all this stuff in my back
and he came in one morning and he went
daddy you're like iron man aren't you
and i went
that's a good way of putting it and once
i knew that he understood
then i felt fine because that was the
only thing that was worrying me is that
how his age does he understand that i'm
not going to be a move for the next
three or four months and blah blah blah
but
um that's scary simon like yeah i mean
not just for him but you like that's i
didn't know like all of that that that's
scary to know that you might i mean
you probably had to work like hell to
get that back right like with
rehabilitation
i got really lucky uh i mean i was like
a millimeter away from breaking my spine
uh which would have been a disaster so
uh in a weird way it was kind of meant
to happen
because i was really pushing my luck i
was buying these
crazy crazy bikes and this particular
bike i bought had so much power
i was thrown about eight feet in the air
landed on my back
in front of eric by the way you know
this is at the front of my house
and the only thing i thought was i can't
lie here and you're not supposed to move
i knew i'd broken my back in that second
somehow managed to get back into my
bedroom i'm lying in my bed
covered in blood waiting for the
ambulance you move
oh yeah i got carried and i'm lying
there hallucinating
about to pass out and i look over and
there's a girl sitting in my bedroom
and i'm like oh hello who are you and
she said i'm here to give you a covered
test
what and she just walked over and gave
me a copy
yeah yeah in the middle of all of this
you're like i think i might not be able
to make it ma'am
yeah i wasn't like top of my list at
that moment
but anyway i went in that night i had an
operation for like seven or eight hours
oh my god yeah and i remember the
surgeon's name is daniel nagasawa he is
if you ever break your back anyone he's
he's the person to go to
the most kind amazing smart person
you'll ever meet
wow and you want someone like that to
trust you know your life
and the wellbeing of it thereafter yep
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help